my question was how do we approach
transmedia as an independent filmmaker a
lot of us are working on very tight
budgets and low resources and having a
hard enough time just trying to create
our one story how do we approach
transmedia and should we be trying to
actually execute all these projects or
just develop them sure so this is this
is a question I get a lot is how does
this apply to the independent filmmaker
how does it apply to somebody who's not
Marvel or Star Wars or Harry Potter and
I think that why I love Star Wars and
Game of Thrones and Marvel and all the
big stuff I think this is more necessary
for the independent filmmaker than even
those big brands primarily because the
independent filmmakers don't have the
P&A budgets that that you know large
movies have and they don't have the
brand awareness that these large brands
already have and so if you're
independent independent filmmaker
operating on you know a hundred thousand
dollar feature a twenty thousand dollar
feature or doing something even more
shoestring the seven thousand dollar
feature you have to figure out every
single way possible to build audience
you have to figure out every single way
possible to compete in a marketplace
with with not just Goliath like Star
Wars and Marvel but but everything
everything competes against everything
now and that's that's that what we're
getting with the where we are in this
entertainment landscape is it's
commoditized its oversaturated and the
competition is just competition for
eyeballs and so what's really
interesting recently Netflix the CEO a
Netflix said their biggest competition
isn't Amazon or Hulu or HBO their
biggest competition is fortnight and
their consists consistently losing to
fortnight which is the video game and so
so why do they say that it's because
fortnight even though it's in a
different industry necessarily from
video games to film or television is
just taking away eyeballs and so now
filmmakers today especially indie
filmmakers are competing not just a
the other films that are in the market
that that are in the festival market or
the films that are streaming films that
are in the theatres they're competing
against the films that are in the
theatres the films that are streaming
every film ever made and anything that's
on TV and anything that's one Apple
music or Spotify and any podcast that's
on the podcast or any video game on
Steam on Xbox Playstation on mobile
you're competing against YouTube you're
competing against Instagram you're
competing against everything because
everything is in competition with
everyone's up for eyes for everyone's
eyeballs you're just competing for the
attention of the consumer or the
audience attention is the game that's
the that's the that's the thing that
that everyone's fighting for you know
again it's like the game of Thrones
it's it's it's everybody's fighting for
the Iron Throne in entertainment
everyone is fighting for the attention
of the audience and there's so many
things pulling attention now it's a it's
a it's a tougher fight and this this has
never been like this ever
and but today Studios they they release
films around new video game releases
when the new Halo video game is going to
drop the studio's avoid that weekend
because they know anyone 18 to 30 is
going to be playing Halo all weekend
they're not going to be going to the box
office
so all that to get back to saying if
you're the the small independent
producer that has a low budget you have
to figure out a way to compete you have
to figure out a way to survive to thrive
to exist in this market and it's tough
to out punch everybody
you can't overpower Star Wars you can't
overpower 4 at night or any of these
other things now you have to be craftier
right so you can't just inundate the
world with marketing with with posters
with trailers you can't buy TV spots so
what can you do and so if you have a
good idea if you have a good story and
you're great storyteller now there's all
these really interesting tools that we
can use to now send your story out and
capture the attention the audience right
and so it's not necessarily about
putting one fishing lure out there now
I'm now that we have so many tools we
can have 10
or twelve fishing lures out there
simultaneously fishing in 12 different
ponds all all the time looking for
audience and and so what I get though is
independent creators saying one I don't
know how to do it or even if they know
how to do it they say that seems like a
lot of work right and that like that to
me that is is such the wrong mindset to
have right because we talked about this
in the first round of interviews we did
is I always encourage independent
filmmakers to be thinking as
entrepreneurs rather than just an artist
and because when you're when you're
creating IP when you're creating when
you're launching a film you're launching
a small business you're you're setting
up an LLC your staffing it with a crew
and you're creating something and you
have to think of yourself just like the
guy who's open in the coffee shop or the
woman that's opening the pizza shop or
the family that's opening of the candle
store down the street you have to have
that same mentality and so though like
if you understand the amount of hours
and hard work it is to launch your own
business then you you they independent
filmmakers understand it in context of a
film they're fine with spending 18 hours
a day on a film set for you know 12
straight days they that's fine because
that's they think that's just within the
context of what they do
but now it's broadened to where now you
have to learn how to you have to learn
how to broaden the scope of that to have
a have a more more skill sets at your
disposal in order to compete in this
crazy market so as a pizza shop owner
can't say well I love to make pizza
that's my thing I'm not gonna worry
about the bookkeeping because you know
who cares about that well I'm not gonna
worry about you know the front of the
house I'm not gonna worry about these
other things all I'm gonna do is make my
pizza the business owner the chef may
but the business owner has to concern
themselves with everything they have to
know the full scope of everything and
they have to be able to put in the hours
and the work to be able to figure that
stuff
if they want a successful business and
even even when they do that most small
businesses fail and they fail primarily
either because of lack of quality or
they don't figure those other things out
right they know they can't figure out
how to compete and so so it's such an
audacious thing to say you want to be a
filmmaker for the rest of your life this
is your dream and what you want to do is
you want to live your life
professionally making movies for the
rest of your life that is such a
first-world crazy dream to have which is
an awesome dream and that that if it's
in your heart 100% go for it but you
have to understand how rare that is and
how audacious that is and the big
disconnect within especially independent
filmmakers is they have this audacious
dream of how they want to live the rest
of their life just making the movie like
their own movies and that's their job
forever they have this audacious dream
but at the same time don't want to go
the same audacious route to be able to
put in the work to learn all the stuff
you need to do to compete to do to make
that happen right and what they say to
me is they say well Tarantino didn't do
that I mean Tarantino broke in like you
know Beyonce doesn't do this or like a
point to they point to these people that
one broke in in a different era first of
all like we talked about how fast things
change now like things have changed from
2019 like 2015 to 2019 completely
different let alone from Tarantino
broken into the mid 90s right like you
it's not the same world it's not the
same thing and and the problem that I
think people have is they look at
Tarantino or they look at Scorsese they
look at these people score say she
doesn't do transmedia I don't need to do
transmedia right the the problem of that
is is you're not Scorsese and it's I but
kind of a tough yet let me just say
you're not Scorsese yet you're not
Tarantino yet right like when I was a
kid played baseball my dad was my
baseball coach and and when you when you
teach kids to play baseball you teach
them to catch a ball with two hands
right you just catch a ball two hands to
the ball wouldn't pop out your glove
right real simple thing my dad takes me
to a professional baseball game and I'm
watching king griffey jr. in the
outfield catching flyballs and he's
catching it with one hand he's catching
behind his back he's catching it like
sort of down by the ground he's doing
all these crazy things and I say dad you
tell me I have to catch with two hands
but king griffey Jr's not catch him with
two hands why can't I just catch with
one hand like him
he and he looked at me and said son if
once you get to be as good as ken
griffey jr. and once you make the major
leagues you can do anything you want
right and so but until then you catch it
with two hands right and so so right now
I think like independent filmmakers
should not map their actions based on
the super-successful top
cream-of-the-crop directors and
producers and writers I think that's a
mistake
as far as craft goes a hundred percent
mapped your actions after those people
like you can learn so much about film
the craft of filmmaking from Tarantino
obviously but I'm not sure I'm not
talking about that because the creation
of the product is just one component of
what it takes to be successful in the
industry right so you have to have sort
of a collection of things sort of a line
that you need to put together to be able
to have a success why p2 we ought to
have a successful business if you mean
filmmakers know this you can make the
greatest movie in the world if you don't
know how to distribute it well no one
will see it you could be the greatest
writer in the world and write the
greatest script but if but if but if
your DP doesn't know what he's doing or
she's doing then the film comes out
poorly like you have like it takes more
than just your individual talent to be
able to pull this thing off and so when
it comes to craft map your actions with
the with the big folks but but at the
same time understand and be self aware
of where you are in your career and you
need to say you know what one day I can
be Tarantino one day I can be Scorsese
but I'm not now
so what do I use what can I use how do I
use everything
possible in order to position myself in
a way that I can get there the path is
there right but the world is different
then when Steven Spielberg started
shooting movies it's just a different
world right and it's good to like read
about Steven Spielberg and the whole
thing but but but you can't say well
Steven Spielberg do this so I don't have
to do it or I can do it because he did
it or whatever right so it's just a
whole different thing so I'm very
bullish on the fact that independent
creators need a multi-platform
transmedia super story more than anybody
in order to compete and in order to be
able to make a splash in this
oversaturated world I don't think it's
just for the big guys
you